JASON: I can still
smell it on me.
I took two showers.
JULIE: I don't think I ever
smelled bad, so you must have
something really wrong.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GUEST SPEAKER: Last time on
5.301, the students made seven
slightly different versions
of penicillin.
Today and tomorrow, they'll be
testing which one is best at
killing bacteria.
They do this by adding seven
different amounts of
penicillin to a constant
number of E.
coli in seven tubes.
The bacteria will be incubated
for 24 hours, and then the
students will measure how much
bacteria is left in each tube.
They'll plot a graph of
bacterial concentration versus
penicillin concentration.
This is called a
killing curve.
The steeper the killing curve,
that better the antibiotic.
GUEST SPEAKER: Don't
sneeze or anything.
ETHAN: 7.0 milligrams of
this, and I don't want
to lose any of it.
LINA: I think we're
doing really well.
We're being so careful.
Everything's working
out perfectly.
GUEST SPEAKER: After a bitter
battle over the biggest
crystal, Jason and Julie
have made up.
JASON: She did it.
She probably spilled it so like,
OK, I have an excuse to
clean up this and get
away from Jason.
I didn't say anything.
JULIE: What did he just
say about me?
JASON: She hates me.
She loves me!
Well, she didn't want
me to say that.
LEALIA: I think we're
almost done.
YI-SHIUAN: We're done.
ANTHONY: You're an
awesome partner.
TENGFEI: So tomorrow, we're
going to see which tube the
bacteria grows and which
tube the bacteria dies.
If they grow, the culture
will become cloudy.
GUEST SPEAKER: The next day, all
the students have to do is
measure how many bacteria
are in each tube.
PROFESSOR: This is how, when you
make a drug candidate, you
can gauge how effective your
drug candidate is.
GUEST SPEAKER: To do that, they
use a spectrophotometer,
which shoots light through the
sample at a detector on the
other side.
If there are a lot of bacteria,
most of that light
is scattered in random
directions and never reaches
the detector.
If there are very few bacteria,
most of the light
makes it through.
GUEST SPEAKER: Trying to
find the line that
fits the data well.
LINA: It feels great, because
I actually know what some of
these things are.
At the beginning I had no idea,
so I was asking around
the entire time.
So I've learned something
during three weeks.
ANTHONY: 0.45.
GUEST SPEAKER: The students plot
the results on the white
board and discuss whose
penicillin is best.
GUEST SPEAKER: How
are the results?
ANTHONY: Did I win?
GUEST SPEAKER: You
tell me who wins.
GUEST SPEAKER: I win!
GUEST SPEAKER: Which
is the best?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah,
Anthony's.
ANTHONY: Mine.
GUEST SPEAKER: Today is the
students' last day in the lab.
Tune in to the next episode
to see how 5.301 wraps up.
GUEST SPEAKER: Just imagine if
you had a president that was a
bachelor, or if you had a
president with no kids.
I think that we're going to have
a gay president before we
have one that doesn't
have a spouse.
Unthinkable.
[MUSIC PLAYING-"HAIL
TO THE CHIEF"]
GUEST SPEAKER: Wait, was he?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah, he was.
GUEST SPEAKER: He didn't
have a wife?
GUEST SPEAKER: Nope.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh my
god, I'm so stupid.
I should definitely fact-check
before I talk.